what are some common ways relationships
fail that you've observed and all the
therapy you've done well the governments
identified what they call the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse so okay
I mean I could just keep it simple and
go off their research so there those are
four different behaviors that they
identify in couples or that you can
identify in couples that are really
highly predictive of a divorce some more
than others but I'll start with the
lower ones
so one thing that we by the way actually
we all do these things these would be in
that five to one ratio you'd want to
stay away from some of these these are
the ones so as they pile up now that
ratio is going to get imbalanced and
then you are headed for a split okay so
the first is criticism
so criticism is when we have a complaint
complaints are normal but instead of
owning our own problems our own feelings
we assume that our perspective is com
the only valid accurate perspective and
so we uh take it upon ourselves to tell
our partner what is wrong with them okay
so there there's essentially no real
belief that they might have a valid
perspective too so this could look like
you never help me out in that with the
house or even
um you're so lazy like can't I just get
you for five seconds to help with the
kids or something like that
um and then what happens is Horsemen
number two defensiveness so uh not
everybody is defensive just because they
were criticized some people just are
more prone to defensiveness than others
none of us really like admitting our
faults so it's pretty natural
but defensiveness is essentially making
excuses or Worse turning it around on
your partner
not accepting any responsibility and
definitely not validating what they're
feeling
now if you get criticized enough or if
you get really flooded that flooding is
what happens when our heart rate goes up
kind of around 100 beats per minute our
frontal lobe shuts down that's our
thoughtful brain our logical brain and
our reptilian kind of hindbrain takes
over our thinking
and we just go into fight or flight in a
white week we just want to annihilate
our partner instead instead of say
anything that would be helpful to the
relationship
so if you're getting flooded you could
do a couple things you could get super
critical you could get contemptuous
which I'll talk about in a second it's
the last Horseman or you do the third
Horseman which is stonewalling and in
their research the gotmans found that
men are actually more likely to
Stonewall I also am someone who
stonewalls but it's where you just sort
of Disconnect from the conversation you
shut down you turn away you can
physically even turn away kind of arms
cross but you're just you're shut off
and stonewalling happens usually because
you get flooded you feel like you can't
win you don't know what to do to make
the situation better it feels pretty
hopeless and talking feels unproductive
so you can see how in a typical
heterosexual relationship the gender
Dynamic we know that women tend to use
criticism more often because they're the
ones that typically raise issues
verbally and then if men are feeling
more criticized that they tend to
Stonewall and it becomes this vicious
cycle of then more criticism but the
criticism is really just a plea to be
loved and get your partner to show you
they care and then the man tends to feel
like he can't do anything right this
isn't even productive if I say anything
I'm just going to make it worse and they
don't have any real you haven't given
them a specific need a solution
something they can do to shine for you
so they turn away and where's the uh
contempt all right so contempt is
criticism on steroids this is what John
gottman calls sulfuric acid for love
nothing will erode a relationship
quicker than contempt contempt is when
you are looking at your partner from a
superior position so you are eye rolling
you are name calling
um there's a mockery mocking even
physical mockery imitating them
imitating their voice contempt is meant
to just take the legs out from your
partner make them feel pathetic
ridiculous
um and it can be abusive but
um most people have engaged in contempt
at some point in their relationship
lower level would be sort of the eye
rolling but that is the biggest
predictor of a split if you allow
yourself to think yeah that mockery or
contempt just a little bit
it's like this weird slippery slope sure
is and the opposite is true
where I just look at a person think wow
isn't that the most like wonderful
creature I've ever seen in my life like
just think that and you notice the
little details about who they are and so
I just observe them the way you observe
like a weird like peacock at a zoo or
something like that attention is
powerful isn't it yeah and it changes it
change you start to notice beautiful
things and then let
uh the things that annoy you yes like
just you're exactly right you're
touching on some really important things
so in relationships we actually know
that wearing rose-colored glasses is
important it's healthy we need it and
it's a choice you're baking right so
there is a saying that uh getting
married is just choosing one person's
faults over another and the reality is
that we may become infatuated with
somebody else as human beings love is an
emotion attraction is emotion an emotion
and as you go through life even if
you're in a committed relationship you
might see Beauty in another and that
person who is novel might seem
attractive to you but if you can
remember that they too have a set of
problems that you would be marrying it
really helps you to
see the beauty in your partner again and
recognize all of their incredible
strengths and all the ways we meld with
the person and become our own family
almost become I mean our lives
intertwine and we grow those oak trees
so she by the way this is a line I read
somewhere that uh when you're wearing
rose-colored glasses all the Red Flags
looks just like Flags
I think it's a good it's a good line uh
so you so you think that humans are
fundamentally all of us have
fundamentally flawed or have flaws
they're unique flaws and they're
basically relationships is just a way to
um
they figure out how the two can fit
together right and we're different so no
matter what we're going to have
differences we are raised differently
than our partner we have different
stories different experiences that
shaped our value systems especially when
it comes to the big ones like parenting
love money
um these principles that are based in
our history
we're going to have differences so are
is this a set of differences you can
accept from somebody and work with do
the benefits and their strengths
um do they make it worth it or is it are
they deal breaker differences